[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's up everybody zacky here from geek
culture bringing you another fantastic
video this time we have the asus zenbook
pro duo now as you can tell this is not
any other ordinary laptop this has not
one but two displays the main one being
a 15.6 inch 4k oled touchscreen display
with hdr support and sharing 5050 with
the keyboard they set another 4k
touchscreen display also known as the
screen pad plus
more on that later now as a creator
myself they're slapped out by some
pretty amazing functions and i know yeah
it might seem gimmicky at first but once
we get to show you the different ways we
can use this laptop with video editing
photoshop multitasking even live
streaming
you might consider getting one for
yourself boy am i excited to show you
guys what this can do and if you are
excited too do give us a like down below
stay tuned roll the thing
[Music]
now before we begin let's dabble a
little bit into the specs here so we
know what we're working with we've got
the two main displays here which is
wonderful is
really good may think that it's the only
feature but what asus has done is to
take it up a notch and give you the best
of the best solid hardware in this
particular model that we have here we've
got the latest 10th gen intercore i9 cpu
we've got 32 gigabytes of ram we've got
the rtx 3070 gpu and not to mention a
blazing fast one terabyte m.2 nvme ssd
whoa
well that's a lot
and what asus is trying to do here is to
target creators like myself i'm talking
about working on 6k 8k footage
there you go if you're a photographer
and work with medium format images
this can help you with that i'm talking
about sound designers talking about
illustrators and even gamers and live
streamers it's an all-in-one package
that will help you with your workflow
and productivity as well all that being
said let's hop over to the secondary
display and talk about the screen pad
plus all right welcome to the screen pad
plus
now i have my recording software plugged
in and everything so don't mind the
wires and the mess
but what's important here is that you're
probably wondering to yourself
why does the screen pop out
like that and that's because of
ergonomic and design
now if you think about it when i close
the laptop it goes flat like so and then
when i open it up it bumps up like so
and this is to allow to get a nicer
viewing angle and on top of that it just
provides more ventilation and cooling
now you got some very high specs so this
laptop you know it's meant to take a lot
of power and with power comes heat
and you know you can feel the fans
blowing like so but it's still pretty
quiet and that's a very good thing
now of course you can see on the sidebar
here we've got somewhat of a control
panel from here i can adjust the
brightness of the screen pad plus i can
go through app navigator so it helps to
rearrange and manage apps between the
main display and the screenpad plus of
course i can disable or enable the
keyboard going back to home screen and
as well as enabling a bigger
touch pad if i wanted to and we have
this four dots and this is just a quick
shortcut to some of the apps if you
wanted a quick key a quick shortcut key
such as card copy paste screen expert
can do that for you you can also
customize it so it's a it's a quick fire
way to actually set up some macros if
you wanted to
next we have handwriting instead of
typing because i'm lazy i can actually
write something and you know type it in
i've also got a number pad
and you know a slew of other apps that
you can try out if you're planning to
get this and book pro duo now with that
being said let's head on to video
editing and i want to show you something
pretty neat
so let's open up premiere pro
boom
there you have it
control panel will actually give you a
customized layout of quick shortcut keys
with dials sliders and buttons
that you can customize yourself
to whatever you need in terms of
shortcut keys for your project so i got
some clips
here at the ready i'm going to show you
just a quick glimpse of what you can do
and you can see here that i got some
time axis adjustments so this will help
me scroll through my timeline if i
wanted to
it's very neat the more aggressive you
are the more you skip ahead or you could
actually go a little bit slow and it
actually goes frame by frame
very interesting
right i've also got a timeline zoom
so if i want to be a bit more precise
into where i want to cut i can do that
and
i can just you know mark a clip if i
wanted to
i can undo if i wanted to or redo so
this just to give you a quick glimpse of
what screenpad plus can do it it just
helps you out with that workflow you
know you don't have to have a loop deck
of those big fancy equipment to just do
the basic things you need to do with the
screen bed plus over here
amazing
and with that it's very easy to
customize as well if you go back to the
control setting
so as you can see we got the control
panel here and this is the layout of
what
happens when you open premiere pro
you're free to change this however you
want
of course i'm fine with this
but you're able to actually delete
things if you wanted to if you want to
clean up the space
let's do that clean up space move things
over
and you can set up hotkeys as well but
this is just one of the few elements
that makes this laptop
well so amazing in my in my personal
opinion
so let's move on to photoshop as well
alright so we got photoshop open and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna open
up
our favorite friend
gary the gorilla
here we go and you can see that the
screenpad plus has changed a little bit
so this time we've got you know brush
size layer opacity we've got a few other
tools that we've added in and this just
gives you know just more finesse and
control over certain adjustments so the
opacity you can see that once we do that
we still bring it up
things like that
it just works and we can zoom in if you
wanted to
right there say hello gary yes brilliant
adjust our brush size as well and the
great thing is i have this
which comes
with
the asus zenbook this is the asus pen
and it works perfectly for both screens
all right so if i wanted um to you know
do more finesse control the screenpad i
can do this i can do the brush opacity
brush hardness and things like that as
well another great thing about the
displays is that it's pantone validated
so you're really getting
very good color accuracy on both screens
all right it's going to come out just as
good as print
so what you're seeing here
it's good to go for prints if you wanted
to do anything with that now of course i
will only work with photos that's why we
have gary the gorilla here
and you know with the asus pen i can
just do a little bit of light editing
here so i'm gonna get the board tool and
start
we don't need to learn it to go away
just making just subtle adjustments to
his face make him a little bit
darker make him a little bit more poppy
so you can see if i'm making any
difference at all so much better let's
look at the difference here
uh-huh
there we go don't you don't you love
that more
damn so good
so let's just say you would not do with
the control panel and you know you just
want to watch something off youtube well
you can do that so you are the master of
your own destiny right that's the most
important thing so i've got a youtube
video ready
and all i need to do is just
bring this and drop it down
and you have full scale you just expand
and full screen this video you can watch
it while you know dabbling to work
and you know it's it's pretty amazing of
course you can do anything when you can
write documents or something while doing
some other work
and it's pretty cool because let's just
say you are reading the geek culture
website okay if you haven't please visit
our website we've got some cool reviews
and stuff but yes enough of the
shameless plug now you can see the
screenpad plus
it's not really that great in terms of
readability like why don't we have the
whole thing blown up on both screens
right if i send this
here
into full screen mode
boy oh boy look at that so if i were to
read an article or perhaps a review
you can see that you know it's so
seamless it's working toe and toe with
both screens and i can just scroll it as
if i would
on a tablet and things like that it's
just wow and don't forget we're able to
go up to three tabs on the screen pad
plus so
again
i have the geek cultural website
i can just drag it to the right side of
here let's open up title title will pop
up in the middle and on top of that we
can also have the number key
all right and then just drag here cool
thing is if this is like
the quintessential workspace and you
don't want to keep opening the same tabs
every time you open the laptop
well the screenpad plus can save all of
these panels at its arrangement right
away so all we need to do is to go into
this four dots again and you can see
we've got like four groups here these
are called task groups so all we need to
do is create a new task group
and you can see that we can have a
preferred layout
so of course i've got my photoshop open
i got my three tabs so obviously you
want to take one on the main screen and
then three apps on the screen pad plus
you can have up to four screens
on the main screen and
three on the screen pack pass it depends
on your whole arrangement
and of course i got one app so i'm just
gonna do that i hit next
and you can either drag the applications
into this box or if you already have the
applications open and you love this
layout
all you need to do is just click capture
and boom
i've got photoshop the number key title
and microsoft itch
captured for me into these three panels
so let's go and test that select my
third task group that i just captured
and of course if the app is a little bit
more demanding to load it's going to
take a little time
but you know you're free to do whatever
you want while waiting it's not that
long anyway isn't it
see look at that all pops up and you're
ready to go how amazing is that
so with this out of the way let's go
into gaming and streaming as well
alright so as you can see i've got
the elgato
4k
60 hooked up to the laptop so we can
have a nice true like free gaming
and on top of that you know this is
something to simulate gameplay and and
you know with all the high specs on this
laptop i don't think you have to worry
too much about gameplay here but yeah
look we are playing on high settings
here
it's all good
let's try and kill some zombies while
we're here
and it's just to simulate that you can
actually do streaming
on the laptop so yeah you can tell that
if you're ever playing games on the main
screen and you know you can lay out
things in the screenpad plus here as
well of course we have a pretty okay
microphone and webcam not gonna lie
but definitely still usable for your
zoom chats and things like that and see
with your zoom chat if you have had
meetings and need to take down notes you
can do it with the screenpad plus and
yeah i got a stream chat here i can look
over at obs and monitor my games and
such as that
so that's that's that's pretty much it
actually
oh yes
okay here we go
oh
yeah coffee helps off helps a lot
there's so much versatility with this
laptop i mean it's got the power to do
the things you need to do multitasking
running multiple apps and tabs and
whatnots it makes you use the
touchscreen functions on the laptop
itself you know we see a lot of laptops
these days with touchscreen functions
and yet we failed to use them i would
say that asus has done a really good job
in really making this
a purposeful and functional laptop in
that sense
then again this is not meant to be a
review so if you really enjoyed this
video do let us know down in the
comments below
if you're gonna get yourself a zenbook
pro duo are there any other creative
users you would like us to do
just let us know down there guys and of
course do check out the links in the
description below to check out more
about the details and pricing give us a
like and do consider subscribing helps
the channel out a lot and click the bell
icon so you can be notified every time
we upload new videos until then this is
zeki
signing off
wahoo
a dual screen
yeah
[Music]